foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Florio joins us now
why now
why is this happening now Mike
well you know it's a great question Dan
because if the objective is to force Dan
Snyder to sell the team they're a couple
weeks too late he's already with the for
sale sign in the front yard but Racine
investigated the team and apparently
there may be more next week as it
relates to allegations of financial
improprieties that's to be determined he
was asked that question at the very end
of the press conference but this is
overdue now it's a creative and
aggressive legal Theory it arises under
the consumer protection laws of the
District of Columbia which are more
easily applied to for example if you
have a label on a tube of toothpaste
that says does not include broken glass
and there's broken glass in it you've
got a problem they're arguing that there
have been lies told about this product
that is aggressively marketed to D.C
residents it is a creative legal
argument but the idea is they've lied
about the Beth Wilkinson investigation
10 months she got to the bottom of a lot
of allegations they brushed it under the
rug they came up with a flimsy excuse
for keeping all of its secret basically
we've promised anonymity to some of the
people who cooperated so we must keep
everything that was determined Under
Wraps which is nonsensical you just
change names you cross out the names and
you put in Jane Doe John Doe whoever
they're going to try to get to the
bottom of this and I fully support any
effort to get to the bottom of this
we're all entitled to know exactly what
Beth Wilkinson did and didn't conclude
and the league has done a great job of
covering it up for the last year and a
half and uh it's almost like a shotgun
blast you're including everybody in here
you got the commissioner you got the NFL
like why is everybody
involved or named in this civil suit
well it's a standard approach anytime
you follow a civil lawsuit you you join
anyone and everyone who potentially is
involved in any way shape or form and
what you ideally like to set up Dan
because I've been there on both sides of
it you want the defendants to start
fighting with each other and they start
fighting with each other as the person
following the law so you just sit back
and wait because somebody's going to
catch the blame here somebody's going
down in flames here and that's why I
think it was so significant that the
commanders have responded to this
basically by saying it's time for the
truth to come out
we'll separate fact from fiction that
means they're not going to rely upon the
procedural technical arguments aimed at
short-circuiting the whole process which
the NFL always does and I guarantee you
the NFL will file a motion to dismiss
the entire case there's no standing the
law is being misapplied anything but
getting to the merits of the case the
Commander's response from yesterday made
me say they got no problem with it and
Dan really why would they he's going to
sell the team anyway what does he care
at this point if this stuff comes out
that creates more momentum for him to
sell it's already on the market do you
really believe Dan Snyder is going to
sell
oh yeah I think he will I think he will
and he's gonna get seven billion they're
lining up already I was told over the
weekend or that that a half dozen
credible majority owners with the money
to buy the team easily had begun kicking
tires on this and this is a flagship NFL
franchise at least it should be and the
idea is once there's a new owner new
owner will be given the keys to the RFK
site go ahead build a state-of-the-art
stadium there that's something Dan
Snyder is never going to be able to do
so I think he is going to do it now with
him you can never rule out anything but
I think it's clearly pointing in that
direction and he's going to get far more
than anyone has ever gotten for an NFL
team yeah but I don't want to buy a team
and inherit the problems that are still
there I mean it was systemic and I don't
know
like what is going to be left over if I
go if I'm Jeff Bezos and Jay-Z and I go
in and buy this what am I buying what am
I getting that goes along with a
football team
well that's part of the negotiation Dan
that happens anytime a company is
acquired by a new purchaser it's part of
the due diligence process you look over
everything you identify all potential
liabilities and you figure out ahead of
time who's responsible am I buying your
problem or are you keeping your problem
are you responsible for these lawsuits
that have been filed or am I because if
I am that affects the purchase price so
I think that can be easily handled when
you're talking about 7 billion Changing
Hands these cases and financially this
new lawsuit drop in the bucket it's
nothing it's nothing and it's of no
concern to the new ownership whatsoever
now there could be other issues that
become a problem for whoever owns the
asset but those are things that you
would all figure out as part of the
negotiation that leads to the final
purchase price Why seven billion dollars
sounds good nice round number I was
going to be between five and six but
there were multiple reports over the
weekend he's looking for seven and Dan
when you're talking about an NFL
franchise I think the balance sheets and
the calculated Book value all that goes
out the window these are assets that are
continuously going up in value
and it's just a matter of time before
that seven billion dollar team is worth
eight or nine or ten I mean Snyder will
have flipped something he paid 750
million for into 7 billion in 23 years
not to mention all the money he's made
throughout the past 23 years but these
things keep going up and up and up the
gambling revenue from the proliferation
of the legalization of sports betting
has helped but someone told me a couple
of years ago before too long the average
random run-of-the-mill team is going to
be worth between 8 and 10 billion
talking to Mike Florio from pro football
talk uh the commissioner in the
crosshairs and you know exposure wise
here's where it's a potential problem
for the commissioner now there's a lot
of ifs here but
bear with me as I sound this out
the argument fundamentally is that the
Beth Wilkinson investigation was
completely covered up by the powers that
be and I remember at the time thinking
well why are they trying to help Dan
Snyder nobody likes Dan Snyder the
owners don't he's not a popular figure
he's probably one of the most unpopular
owners the League's ever had they're
trying to help themselves because they
didn't want to create a precedent where
disgruntled employee makes the right
complaint at the right time it gets
traction the league feels compelled to
have an investigation and then an
investigator shows up and starts looking
under rocks and
in corners and you find things and then
you get another owner that's got to sell
the team before you know it I think they
deliberately hid this information
because they don't want to create a
standard that gets applied in the future
to other owners and if if once we start
investigating depositions people under
oath documents being reviewed text
messages that were casually sent without
anyone ever thinking that anyone's ever
going to see what was sent on that text
message
if if they uncover
you know the old cover-up is worse than
the crime the old Watergate standard if
they uncover a deliberate effort by the
NFL to concoct a phony ass story for
keeping all this stuff under wraps
that's when people at 345 Park Avenue
need to be concerned so Snyder's already
selling the team you can't do anything
more to him than he's already chosen to
do to himself but if they can show that
the league came up with this strategy
for hiding this evidence to benefit the
league and to protect the other owners
that's when people who are sitting in
that office suite in Manhattan are going
to have to start sweating out what may
happen to them Mike have a great weekend
thank you and so see you then great
talking to you that's Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host and uh
contributor to NBC football night in
America